hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game that happened in
round 14. it's the penultimate round of
the iranian championship that took place
um and it's uh it's a really nice game
it was won by parham aksulu as the title
suggests that we've had him on the
channel uh many times and he's playing
against
uh massoud musapur he was the 2015
world under 18 champion and it's a
really really an awesome game
this is the neighbor's cat if you guys
you guys are wondering who this guy is
uh and uh well uh without further ado
let's just check it out as
it's really really uh an outstanding one
and we're gonna discuss the standings a
little bit later because what the
maxulou did in this tournament is
just out of this world so uh with uh
white he opens with
d4 we have d5 knight to f3 knight
to f6 and now c4 so nothing out of the
ordinary here this is a
fairly standard stuff uh we have e6
going for uh
now for the queen's gambit decline setup
uh and g3 now preparing to fiance to the
light square bishop
uh and so on so here bishop the b for
check
uh and now bishop to d2 here black kind
of forced
whites to develop this bishop to a weird
d2 square
and here uh the the most common options
for black are just retreating the bishop
bishop d6 or bishop to e7
but here we actually have a5 and this is
again nothing new it has been played
before
uh we have bishop to g2 maxwell who just
continues development and
now d captures on c4 and this is um
quite often whenever white uh fiance
does the bishops like this you will see
this d
captures in c4 capture uh but also
castles is
also a fairly fairly good move here uh i
i think even the most played one
uh so here d captures on c4 like i said
and
queen to c2 now developing the queen
also putting pressure on that c4 pawn
and here black wants the uh well
prevent white of course from recapturing
he will uh cement that c4 pawn by
playing b5 but first he's gonna trade
bishop captures on d2 with knight
captures
and again interestingly queen captures
is the most
uh most common move here uh kinda
uh saying that the knight might not be
all that great on d2
and that the knight maybe belongs on c3
but here we have knight b
captures on d2 maybe trying to confuse
his opponent a little
bit now with a double attack on the c4
pawn and the b5 now
just nicely uh defending that c4 pawn
but as usual when we see
such a big mass of pawns like
a huge pawn chain on one side of the
board uh
one player will try of course to
undermine it and that's exactly what we
do here
a4 we have to undermine the pawn chain
create weaknesses and then we're gonna
try and pick up the pawns and black
isn't really worried
about the rook and a8 being so
vulnerable because there really is no
good
good jump with the knight so that's not
really relevant
we have c6 now defending the b5 pawn
uh and now while you could continue
undermining the pawn chain with b3
instead we have castles
uh we have castles by black as well and
now b3 here maxulo undermines the pawn
chain
uh we have c captures knight captures uh
and now
bishop to a6 so here you have to again
uh decide what to do uh you can't really
win any material here because after pawn
captures
bishop will capture and then you haven't
really done anything and you just
gave black a nice past a pawn so this is
not something you want to do
so instead uh maxo goes rook f to d1
uh he wants to shift his knight over to
e5 and c5 and to do that
uh he needs the d4 pawn defended and
this is why
the rook belongs on d1 we have b
captures on a4
and now not recapturing but rather
knight to c5 and this has all been
played before so
nothing new here uh bishop to b5 adding
another defender to the
to the a4 pawn also getting the bishop
out of the way you do not want to allow
this trade and also you're continuing uh
to put pressure on the e2 pawn
so here knight the e5 as we said this is
now possible as the rook defends the d4
pawn and these two guys are now
uh not maybe yet monster knights but
they are very very impressive uh
knights so here queen to d6 uh just
developing preparing to bring the other
pieces into the game
and now there is one game from 2007
between romanin and london
where knight captures on a4 was played
sorry where knights the c4 was played
with an attack on the queen
and that game ended by black winning
this but here we have knight captures on
a4 by maxulou
and it is only now as of move 16 that we
have a completely new
game so let's see how black deals with
this we have
knight to a6 so just uh continuing
development and
now knight to b6 with an attack on the
rook
so it's a very it's a very interesting
idea because if uh well if the knight
doesn't really
have anything to do there then it could
be very risky but
uh he he does so here knights the b4
first a nice in-between move
attacking the queen queen to d2 and only
now
rook to a6 getting the recorded away
attacking the knight
knight back to c for now with an attack
on the queen
and of course black not interested in
trading bishop for night black just goes
back
queen to c7 and the queen is very nicely
placed there
and uh not only that black has a past
pawn and if black can start pushing that
pass pawn could be
i could be very dangerous for the moment
it's not possible uh as you you have to
prepare it and not only that the
the knight is kind of still uh on v4 so
here
knight captures on a5 and this is the
this is where it gets really good
because now we've removed the defender
of the knight so here if trades we can
just
trade it's not nothing to worry about so
instead we have bishop captures an e2
now saying okay if you capture here i'm
just going to capture on a5 and then
everything is perfectly
perfectly fine for both of us captures
captures and
that's just it we continue with
black being black being up this one pawn
but shouldn't really
uh shouldn't really be that difficult
for white to
to keep an eye on everything so instead
after bishop captures an e2
we have queen captures on b4 sacrificing
the exchange here
uh but it's not really an exchange
sacrifice but you'll see
you'll see what happens next so bishop
captures on d1
uh we have knight e captures uh on c6
grabbing that pawn and now you're also
preparing knight to e7 check and this is
gonna be very very good
so here the the bishop is still under
attack yes you've grabbed the exchange
but you have to save your piece so
bishop back to h5 and now comes the
knights the e7
check and that's the that's the point
king h8 only move if you don't want to
give up the queen so kink the h8 and now
knight
the g6 with check and now you can't go
back because if you go back it's just
checkmate
no point in doing that so of course the
knight has to be captured and then
queen captures rook this is how we win
back our exchange so bishop captures on
g6
uh we have queen captures and f8 with
check knight g8
only move we have to block this uh and
then now queen
back to c5 and here uh maxwell is saying
that
okay uh the material is equal now uh and
i'm offering a queen trade if you trade
here then this pawn is pretty much
unstoppable the c6 square already
covered twice we're just going to push
it
most likely should be enough to win this
so instead
rook to a7 defends the queen and now
rook to a3 so the rook was on the
defended on a1 he rooked a3 just
improving the position now we can play
moves like knight
to c4 or for a rook trade uh and so on
so here
queen to e7 and now
uh white doesn't do anything rashford
just continues improving the position so
here
h4 we have h5 by black
and now bishop to f3 again putting
pressure on that h5 pawn for the moment
not really all that important because
black can always decide to capture here
but
uh that is only going to go in white's
favor
so knight to f6 black now needs to
reactivate this knight
and knight the c for now as we've
already mentioned
uh white wants the trade off some pieces
we have rook to c7
attacking the queen and now comes rook
to a8
with check we have king to h7 and now
getting the queen out of the way
queen to b5 and here we have a very very
uh interesting position because black uh
can
do a a lot of things here some of some
of them are good some of them
not so good and here if black wanted
black can basically force a draw with
rook to a7
uh if if you trade off this rook then
it's very unlikely that either side will
be able to push for more than a draw
and if you don't then black rook just
continues following this white rook at
some point you you will have to capture
and that's just it
i mean there there are of course more
moves to be played but it is very
unlikely that we would see
a a decisive outcome here so instead
after queen to b5
white tried uh black tried to take
advantage of this queen and knight being
aligned like this bishop to d3 seems
like an
excellent idea and it would be if there
wasn't for one very specific
idea so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find what maksulu played
while i give you a couple of seconds
also the the cat is still sleeping here
if you guys want to check him out like
it's the neighbor's cat but you know
it's cool there you go say hello mr cat
see he's always he's always very sleepy
and he he really enjoys sleeping here
for some reason
uh but okay uh i hope you guys uh
enjoyed
that cat uh and uh regarding the the
position
uh for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen to b8 so here you're giving up a
piece
in order to really do some damage point
is if the knight is captured
by the bishop or by the rook doesn't
really matter queen to
h8 with check king to g6 and now
rook to g8 this is the move that uh
uh that mossad kapoor missed uh because
i mean who wouldn't miss this it's it's
such a disgusting move to the face
uh now uh queen captures and g7 is
coming and of course if you capture the
rook
then the bishop and queen are attacking
this pawn that the knight was defending
so just queen captures with
check king f6 and now queen to g5
would be checkmate so this is really
incredible the knight is definitely off
limits
so here king the h6 was played but now
comes
knight to e5 with an attack on the
bishop on d3
so we have to move the bishop bishop to
h7 was played to block any future checks
here
and now comes a queen to h8 and this is
also a very very interesting line
i will however show an uh alternative
here because it's just out of this world
i know you guys enjoy seeing such ideas
but queen to b2 here is just
uh deadly i mean threatening queen to d
to check
and okay for the moment you really don't
care because you can just let's say play
something like bishop to f5 then you're
gonna move the knight maybe g5
but the it it doesn't work let's say
rook h8 check
now you move the knight okay now you
will have g5 the queen and everything is
guarding that so you don't really care
about queen to d2
but here comes uh here comes the the
beauty d5
you open up this diagonal and now also
threatening
not just queen to d to check but if
black blocks check then you also have
support
to push d6 and then black loses a lot of
material here
so e captures on d5 would have to be
played and now
knight captures on f7 completely
crushing everything
uh and if queen captures then we play
then finally we play queen to d2 check
king to g6 and now of course bishop
captures on h5
and that's just it uh you don't really
have an option here because
if you move the king you will lose the
queen and if you pick up the bishop then
queen to g5
is checkmate so this is not uh
uh that difficult to find but um i
there there are more winning ideas here
so queen to b2 is not the only winning
movie
if it was i'm sure maxullu would have
gone for it uh he instead went for queen
to h8 which is just as potent only i i
kind of prefer that line
a little bit more but okay
now how do you defend here what do you
play uh what what should you play
not it's very hard to even find the move
for black here
black played queen to b4 try to start
some trouble here maybe you can do some
checks maybe you can capture some pawns
here
and hope that you can survive here but
it doesn't work rook to
f8 now with a double attack on the f7
pawn
we have queen captures on d4 there's
really nothing you can do about this
and now knight captures on f7 and it was
in this position that masud musa
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
uh what can you do you are in check and
that's just it
if you go kink the g6 it doesn't work
you have this amazing
knight to g5 move and now this bishop
cannot go anywhere
and well it doesn't really matter what
you do if something like
queen to c4 you're trying to keep an eye
on everything
we can just play bishop to e for check
sacrifice some material
and now it doesn't matter if the queen
captures an e4 then we can just play
rook captures here with check and after
g captures we just capture the queen and
of course this is not completely winning
uh and instead after bishop uh if
instead after bishop
to e4 check we don't capture with the
queen we play knight captures
sorry knight captures on e4 then we no
longer defend
the h7 bishop and queen captures on h7
is just
checkmate so that's one way to do it
another way after knight captures an f7
would be just
to capture with the rook but just the
real captures now you're down material
there's really not not much control
you can do there's really nothing you
can do here as black
uh so after knight captures on f7 with
check massage
resigned and another great victory for
parham
maksoulu who wins the penultimate round
not only that i will now show you the
standings
this is just uh this is just outstanding
uh these are outstanding standings uh as
you can see
uh he started kind of slow i mean it's
not slow as you
phase two grand masters and one
international master he started with two
draws in the win
and then he got 12 wins in a row
12 wins in a row in the uh official
iranian championship and he won first
place with 14 out of 15 points this is
uh this is simply amazing stuff so
i'm very very happy for him and uh well
i
went through through the games this is
the one i enjoyed most uh so i did the
show
i decided to show this one uh so yeah uh
that's
the game uh hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank the bonjour kappa
uh emil ulametz uh uh brandon martel
kuhn software and art and science
science of
kinesiology llc for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
and also we have a new top contributor
to the channel it is blockfolio
uh so thank you for that they only sent
the contribution that they did not send
me a message or anything so
at least uh i i decided to show you you
guys uh
this from their website this is from
their homepage so here is a
uh a few words of from portfolio from
their ceo
uh edward moncada uh so so there you
have it uh
if you guys are interested you can check
it out uh you can pause the video and
then
read it so i thought it would be a nice
gesture to
at least show something uh but yeah once
again i hope you guys enjoyed it uh
and yeah as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day